-Welcome back.
You have a great mustache.
-Thank you.
It's actually, it's --
it's quite versatile,
I've discovered,
because it's, you know,
when I'm dressed nicely,
it's very English.
It's very erudite.
But if I'm in jeans
and a T-shirt,
I'm Schneider
from "One Day at a Time."
You know I mean because it's...
[ Laughs ]
-Of course. Yeah.
Do people
recognize you?
No, it's quite --
It's an amazing disguise.
It's like Clark Kent
with the glasses, right?
It's all the takes. It's just --
And no one knows him.
-Yeah, that always
made me wonder.
-I just -- I just did my thin
little mustache,
and I smiled at people
who I think recognize me,
and they're like,
"Ew, that guy..."
[ Laughter ]
"That guy makes porn
in his basement or something"
-[ Laughter ]
-You know?
-I think
the first time we met
was when you hosted
"Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-And you were fantastic.
Well, you were a great host.
-21 years ago.
-That was 21...?
-Uh-huh, I know.
We've been friends for 21 years.
Do you remember the musical
guest when you hosted?
-Yeah, it's
a little embarrassing.
My musical guest
was Jay-Z and Beyoncé.
Yeah. This was -- This is...
-Yeah, there's --
there's me at the end there.
And I'm --
My musical knowledge
sort of died
with Freddie Mercury.
So I -- I came on, I said,
"Who's my guest?"
And they said, "Jay."
And I went, "Wow.
Now Beyoncé, she's in --
she's in that girl group.
What does Mr. Z do?"
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. Z.
-I'm really to this day,
very embarrassed about it.
-Is that the --
That's an amazing show.
-[ Laughs ]
-That was fantastic.
-And you and I
had a sketch together
I was just
reminding you of before.
He does this
radio morning jock.
[ Nasally voice ]
And he does this voice.
The man on the box.
-[ Nasally voice ] Absolutely.
Yeah, what do you, yeah.
-Let's -- Let's talk
to the man on the box.
-[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, we did all these bits.
By the way,
I've been loving the podcast.
Speaking of radio.
The podcast you do with Sean.
-[ Normal voice ]
Oh, with Sean, yeah.
-Sean Hayes.
I just --
-It's called just --
It's called
"Just Jack & Will."
And it's about a show
that I'm not going to talk about
because out of respect
for -- for the strike we're on.
But it is -- the pod--
They'd allowed us
to talk about the podcast
and it's so much fun to be back
with my old buddy Sean.
-You're so funny together.
And it's basically
talking about episodes.
But you --
-Well, he got --
So this is crazy.
We were at lunch one day
and he said,
"We should do a podcast
about maybe the show."
And I said,
"Well, great."
Because I still watch it
all the time.
I can talk with
with tremendous fluency.
And he said, "I've never --
I've never watched it."
[ Laughter ]
I said,
You've never watched it?!"
So -- so here I am,
I'm rewatching.
And he's -- he's like
someone with amnesia.
It's like I --
-Yeah, he's seeing it...
-We were gay, best friends!
[ Laughter ]
-It's so funny.
And gosh, you guys
have just, like, the timing
because obviously you worked
together for so long.
-It's an old belt.
-It's just --
-Oh, it's unbelievable.
Congrats on "The Cottage,"
by the way.
-Thank you.
It has been so exciting.
We've been running
since early July and it is.
Folks, when you leave here,
get a ticket.
It's really fun.
-Yeah.
It's through October 29th
at the Hayes Theater.
And I got to say, you got
one of the biggest honors ever
that I'm always --
I go there all the time.
But Sardi's...
-Yeah.
-...is a restaurant
in the theater district.
-Right beside our theater
and famous
for the caricatures on the wall,
some of them dating back
so far, you don't even
know who they are.
You can't read
the signature, but...
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, I was -- I got one.
I got one a few weeks ago.
-This is a big deal.
I want to show
the picture of you and you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is at Sardi's.
Not bad. It looks good.
-It's not bad.
There's so many
pictures that you can't --
you can't figure how is there --
how's there room for me.
I would come in most nights
after the show,
and the very elegant maitre d'
would say, "Soon is your turn."
And then three days before,
he said,
"Any day now you
will be right here.
And I said, "Here,
like, right here
in the front foyer, the front?"
He said, "Yes."
I said, "For how long?"
He said,
"About a week."
[ Laughter ]
-I'll take it. You go.
-Yeah, yeah, I...
-I'll take it.
Yeah, why not?
But you're being directed by
the one and only
Jason Alexander.
-Yes.
-Who is -- Who is...
-Obviously a legend.
-...the funniest.
-But also an old friend,
not from -- from NBC,
not from sitcom days.
But we were dads
at the same school
and we used
to do parents nights
and we'd perform ridiculous
things with other dads.
Nowadays, this school has,
like Dave Grohl and Beck
are dads, you know.
But back then it was -- it was
Jason and I and Steve Carell.
It was -- it was -- it was
sitcom dads, basically.
-But now --
now you're rocking out.
-Yeah, we're rocking out.
-Now you have rock performances.
-And he has -- he has directed
the hell out of this.
It is really hilarious.
-Oh, he's so funny.
What is -- what is CADs, though?
Can you explain what this is?
-Oh, boy.
They're going to kill me.
CADs are just
a bunch of pals
that we've all worked
together or known.
Richard Kind and Bryan Cranston
and Steven Weber
and Spencer Garrett.
There's Noah Wyle.
And we just slowly but surely,
over the last few years,
before COVID
and then through COVID,
we get on Zoom
and eat together on Zoom.
It's just a -- it's just
a bunch of dining.
This is a great --
It's like a who's who.
This is super fun.
-It's -- It's an amazing
group of guys.
But now it's even grown even --
These are more,
These are more CADs.
Who are these?
-More, CADs, yeah.
Who else we got there?
-That's LeVar Burton.
Laurence Fishburne is there.
-Alfred Molina.
-Alfred Molina. It's...
-I want to be at this --
this lunch.
You're not going to --
It's a very tough ticket.
Very...
-Okay, I understand.
I understand. I understand.
-[ Chuckles ]
-When you do "The Cottage,"
by the way,
I wanted to ask this because --
Do you know
if anyone's in the audience,
if someone's coming to see you
or if they're a celebrity or...?
-Well, some of those guys
came opening night,
but other nights,
I don't generally
find out until after.
It's crazy, I have three
and a half years of COVID.
I never got it.
Never.
And then I've had it twice
in the run of this show.
Twice in the summer.
No.
And I very virtually
no symptoms,
but still had to take
five days off
and still had
to follow the protocol.
-Absolutely, Sure.
-So my understudy went on.
He was great, but the second
time I was like, "Ugh."
And that night my understudy
went on for the second time,
Pierce Brosnan
showed up.
[ Audience groans ]
And I was just like,
"Zewh! Really?!"
-Yeah, He's James Bond?
-And somebody said,
"Just --
If you ever run into Pierce,
just tell him it was you.
He won't remember."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. No.
Can we say -- talk about what
"The Cottage" is about, please?
This is a -- it's a new play
by a young American woman
named Sandy Rustin.
And, yet, it is 100 years old.
It takes place in 1923.
It's an English cottage.
And all these couples
are cheating on
each other
with each other.
It's a classic
British sex farce.
[ Laughter ]
And it's -- Yeah.
And it's --
My cast is incredible.
Just all Broadway vets and --
and Alex Moffat
from "SNL." Yes.
-Oh, from "SNL."
Oh, I love Alex Moffat.
-Alex and I play brothers.
He's got an even
bigger mustache.
-No way.
Please give him my best.
-I absolutely will.
He's brilliant.
-And I know that you're
a busy doing the show.
You're going to go right
from here to the show.
It means so much to me
that you came on the show.
-It means so much to be asked.
-I love you, buddy.
-It's nice to see you
after all this time.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-And break a leg.
-Come and see it, 3 more weeks.
-Talented dude right there.
Eric McCormack, everyone.
"The Cottage" is running now
through October 29th
at the Hayes Theater.
[ Cheers and applause ]
- We'll be right back.
Stick around, everybody.